They, he is not asked. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala is not
asked. And is not in a position
to be questioned by anyone.
With regards to what he does.
He does what he chooses.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala. Whatever
he wills he does. And noone is
in an authoritative position or
in any position to ask Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala to explain
himself. Rather, it is they who
are asked It is Allah and Allah
alone who has the authority to
ask. his creation, and to ask
others about their actions, to
explain themselves, to justify
themselves. But Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala is not in a position
to be asked or questioned and
required to justify his actions
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala then
mentions
He says, yet rather have they
taken other gods besides Allah
which they worship This comes
in the form of a question but
it is actually a rhetorical
question. As if he is saying,
how could they do this? What
could lead a person to worship
other than Allah alone? They
worship these stones. They
worship other people. They
worship what they claim as the
angels. They worship what could
cause them to do this. Is logic
the reason behind that? Or is
revelation? The reason behind
that. Because evidences are two
types. We have logic. We have
revelation. These are the two
types of evidences. Logic is
what is preceded Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala said in the
verse prior He says, if there
were any other gods aside from
Allah Then, the heavens and the
earth would be spiraled into
chaos and ceased to be. This is
logic. Logic dictates that it
is impossible for there to be
more than one god, more than
one creator. This is an
impossibility. Why? Because if
we have two intelligent agents
who are omnipotent, able to do
all things. then it's
impossible for these two, let
alone more than two, but it is
impossible for these two
intelligent, omnipotent agents,
to agree on everything. They're
going to disagree eventually
and this one is creating and
this one is creating and they
create in disagreement. The
creation would not be in
harmony. The heavens and the
earth would be thrown out of
whack.
And if they disagree, one has
to be superior to the other. It
can't be a standoff. It can't
be a stalemate. and if they
were to disagree and one were
to overpower the other, then,
the other is not a god and
cannot be a god, an omnipotent
creator, who has been
overpowered by another. This is
a logical fallacy, impossible.
And so, logic dictates that
this is an impossibility How
about revelation? Does
revelation tell us otherwise?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
say to them, bring forth your
evidence. Bring forth your
evidence for this. You have no
logical evidence and you have
no? You have no reasonable,
logical, deductive evidence,
and you have no? Evi by way of
revelation. He says, this is
the this is the revelation
of my people, my followers, and
those who have preceded me. So,
if we examine thee, the the
gospels of Isa Alaihi Salam,
the Torah of Musa, the Psalms
of David, all of them have a
clear message which is all the
same and that is Allah is one
alone without any partners.
Only he is to be worshiped.
Even to day. Even the gospels
that is claimed to be the
New Testament or what is
claimed to be the Torah of of
Musa, the Old Testament or what
is claimed to be the Psalms of
David. The Psalms, this is kind
of roughly collected into the
Bible. There's a lot of
fabrications in this book. It's
not a pure book. It's chains of
narration are broken, Chains of
transmission are wildly
inaccurate and not only that
but the book itself contradicts
itself in many places. but even
with all of these additions
that have been added to these
books. Even with all of these
fabrications, we can still see
a pattern and that is the
oneness of Allah and the
worship of Allah without any
partners. If you were to ask an
educated Christian, an educated
Jew, how many gods are there?
They will say, one, one god,
one creator. why then do you
worship other than Allah? Why
do you then worship Asa? Why
are you worshipping Jesus? Why
is no. Well, you know, three is
one and one is three and we
can't we have this trinity that
is introduced to us by a very
obscure verse. In John,
and this very obscure verse can
be interpreted in many
different ways and you find all
of this kind of you find all of
this kind of mental acrobatics,
right? To try to arrive at the
conclusions that they have
arrived at. But if we look at
the clear statements, we see a
very clear pattern and that is
the oneness of Allah and the
worship of Allah without any
partners. Allah
[Silence]
none is rightfully worshiped
but I, so, worship me and they
claim that al Rahman has taken
children for himself. We
mentioned that this is a Mekki
chapter. This is a chapter that
was revealed in Mecca. and the
pattern of the Mechan chapters
is that the Meccan chapters
rarely deal with thee
reputation of the Jews or
Christians because Judaism is
something that was kind of
referred to and referenced in
the Medeny chapters because
when they made when they
migrated to Madinah, there were
Jews there but in Mecca, there
were no Jews, there were no
Christians, they were just very
scarce. And so, the the the
beliefs of the Jews and the
Christians were not really
referenced or refuted with any
detail in the Meccan chapters.
This is in the later chapters.
However, there is something
that we can almost kind of call
retrofitting. What does that
mean? A verse that is general
is revealed. Regarding certain
circumstances that were there
at that time. But as we go
forth in time, ten, 15 years
later, perhaps something new
arises that also fits into the
generality of that verse. So,
the scholars of Islam will use
that verse as an as an evidence
with regards to that thing as
well because it fits into the
generality of the verse. This
is fine. But if we were to
research to whom this verse is
actually referring to directly
we will see that this is
referring to the beliefs of the
polytheist of Mecca and
surrounding areas. Most
specifically is a Shokani
mentioned in
Hosea, Hosea is a tribe of the
Arab Pagans that claimed in
their belief system that the
angels were the daughters of
Allah.
And so, they made this claim
but Allah refuted saying
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
is free of this claim.
in the Arabic language when you
say subhanallah. What this
means is Allah is free of any
imperfection. is a proclamation
of the
lack of imperfection that may
be ascribed to Allah. That this
is this is an imperfection
which Allah is above and
beyond. So, he refutes this by
saying
rather these angels of Allah,
they are servants and he
mentions it here in the
masculine. He says he didn't
say he says which means that
Allah is refuting not only that
they are female but he is also
refuting that they are.
ascribed to him as a child
would be ascribed to his
father. So, in this statement,
we have a reputation of the
claim that any of the angels
are feminine, female, and a
reputation of the claim that
any of the angels are
anythi
ng more to Allah than
servants of his. They are not
his children. They are not his
relatives. They are not they
are servants of his. They are
all below Allah. Subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
with regards to the gender of
the angels, we have clear
evidence in the Quran clear
verses that refute the notion
that any of the angels are
female This is clearly and
explicitly refuted in the
Quran. So, we are positive that
there are no female angels.
Are they male? We don't have
any evidence saying that they
are necessarily male. They
could not be male or female.
But they certainly aren't.
female
though ascribing a gender to
thee, angels is not something
that we have an evidence for.
We just have an evidence of a
lack of gender and that is that
they are certainly not female.
He says subhanahu wa ta'ala
they are honored servants with
him. That is the height of
their potential and their
stature with Allah. They're
nothing more than that. They
are not more than servants of
Allah. That is it. We cannot
raise people, creatures, above
their level of stature, which
Allah has given them. And their
level, their stature with Allah
is that they are servants of
Allah who are honored by Allah.
That's the extent of it we
don't add to that. This is
extremism and extremism in
beliefs leads to leads to
damnation.
[Arabic recitation]